stay there stay there while they've
spent the last 11 days focused on
evacuating those in need very soon
british troops will need to start
extracting themselves
they've already reduced their footprint
to a minimum to maximize the time spent
helping families like these but with a
u.s deadline of next tuesday to exit
british forces are set to go even sooner
a perilous maneuver in an already
dangerous operation there is going to be
a moment of profound risk
where the military force that's holding
the airport has to reduce until you get
down to the last
flights out
and at that stage you are absolutely
relying on the taliban to hold the ring
outside the airport so that there is a
gap
between the last
military boot leaving the ground and the
taliban taking charge of their airport
added to all this a senior source has
warned of a very high risk of a
terrorist attack against them the
biggest threat is from an affiliate of
islamic state
islamic state coruscan or isis-k
emerged in around 2015 as part of an
expansion of the group's reach outside
iraq and syria
the khorasan region historically covers
afghanistan pakistan central asia and
parts of iran isis k fighters are
thought to number up to 2200 though this
figure could well be rising given the
security vacuum left by departing
foreign troops they're mainly based in
kunar and nangahar provinces and are
responsible for some of the worst
attacks in afghanistan
one at a maternity hospital in kabul
last year killed 24 people including
mothers and newborns
the groups led by a militant called
shahab al-muhajeer previous leaders have
been killed or captured by u.s and
afghan forces
islamic state also no friend of the
taliban and how taliban leaders
negotiated with the u.s in their return
to power the concern is that they might
try to do something to disrupt the
agreements that have been struck and you
know launching an attack on kabul
airport now as this evacuation was
taking place would be a very good way of
causing some trouble uh for the taliban
and the west and potentially causing
everything to unravel
it's a risk british forces have to be
ready for in these final difficult days
debrahim sky news